let's see what's happening on the phone
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty we'll start with our caller
from the five one two area code caller
from five one two tell us who you are
and what's on your mind today one of the
callin and just see what's your opinion
on the Alex stone conspiracy or not it
really conspiracy but what's happening
to ellen stones across social we need a
platform i will answer that but I have
to know are we on speakerphone right now
do you have a son speakerphone
well you don't okay all right well that
that's uh maybe we'll talk about what
kind of phone you're on later I'm
curious about that listen so here's the
thing with Alex Jones he clearly was in
violation of YouTube's Terms and
Conditions so it makes perfect sense
that YouTube at a certain point would
say enough is enough
the only problem I have is that the
timing of when YouTube decided to kick
him off is when there was a broader
public tidal wave of negative commentary
about Alex Jones and it doesn't
necessarily correlate to sort of like a
strict adherence to when someone
violates the rules we kick them off
because if you think back to when ad
pocalypse hit in April of 2017
we had videos demonetised while Alex
Jones had videos with violent footage
from Syria which had Dodge Ram truck
advertisements running on them so I
guess you know my issue is not that
anything illegal was done my issue is
that the timing is arbitrary and I have
some concern about the blurry sort of
gray area with which YouTube could do
this to almost anyone doing news
coverage at any time yeah in my opinion
I don't think well some of the stuff was
quite violent about what Alex Jones I
haven't seen a lot of this stuff stuff
but I do know that it is a form of
personal opinion of a certain subject
and people just have to believe it or
not so yeah but it's more than that I
mean just just because something is
opinion just because something is
opinion doesn't mean it's exempt from
consequences terms and conditions on the
platforms where it appears like I guess
I just I just don't think it's relevant
that it's his opinion I don't know that
that impacts the legality or correctness
of what YouTube did one way or the other
well we just have to grin and bear it
oh yeah yeah I just don't think that
that's that's an argument there are
there still reuploads of Alex Jones
podcast on YouTube yeah other users are
re uploading content sure and that's I
don't know what's gonna happen with that
but okay sounds like your connection is
disintegrating so I'm gonna let you go
but I do appreciate the call and I
believe you that we weren't on
speakerphone I believe the caller Pat
thank you very much